Learning multiple languages at the same
time is not something I would recommend
to the average Joe, but the reality is
that I'm doing just that, I started
learning three languages at the same
time. Hi, my name is Luca from Luca lampariello.com
and today you're going to see how you
can learn one, two, three, four or more
languages every single day. So the
languages I'm learning right now and
every single day are: Danish, Greek, and
Hungarian. There's a specific reason why
I've listed these languages in this
order. In fact, every single day I always
start by learning the language in which
I have the lowest level. In this case
Danish. I just started learning Danish
some three weeks ago, and I consider
myself a beginner. On the other hand, I've
been learning Greek for two years and
Hungarian for almost three and I have
reached a more or less a lower and upper
intermediate level in these languages, which
means that it takes much less effort for
me to learn Greek, or Hungarian for that
matter than it does Danish and that's
the reason why I do Danish first.
Establishing priorities is a crucial
factor in learning multiple languages at
the same time, because as I said before: time. It's not just a matter of time, we
tend to use this word, to throw this word
around, but the truth is there's two
factors which are just as important as
time and which are energy and your
concentration. And they're all entangled.
The reason why I always wake up early in
the morning to learn languages is
because I know that my energy is at its
top in the morning and at its lowest in
the evening so that's the reason why my
rule number one for learning multiple
languages at the same time is actually
wake up early and hit the books in the
language at its lowest level, which is
Danish in this case. Those who've been
following me for quite some time
know that I love ASSIMIL, which is a
small book, a perfect learning resource
for beginners and I'm using that and I'm
applying my bi-directional translation
technique to it, which requires energy
and most of all, requires a lot of
concentration, for at least 30 to 40
minutes.
So after spending 30 to 40 minutes
learning Danish, I can do a number of
things: I normally organize things so
that I can do Greek after doing Danish
so that I can actually kill "two birds
with one stone" - actually there's a lot of
birds that you can hear here because
we're shooting outside - and the reason
why I as I said I do Greek is because I
know it's less than I do Hungarian, but
the good thing is that I can relax a
little bit more because I'm not using a
ASSIMIL anymore. I still do listen and
read at the same time but sometimes for
example I talk to my ITALKI teachers so
it's a different thing I started really
enjoying the language that's the reason
why this comes second is because I know
that I have to do it but I also want to
do it because it started being fun so on
a normal day I set things up so that I
can start working around 9:00 and I
dedicate time to learning Danish and
then Greek (before work) but sometimes,  like today for
example which is filming day, some days
are more intense than others, so when I
have really intensive days I try to make
sure that at least I take care of the
"last born" of the family maybe the other
one's a little bit like grown-ups and
they think can take care of themselves
so to speak. So don't beat yourself up
when it comes to learning multiple
languages at the same time, if you can't
learn three languages every single day,
that's not the end of the world as long
as you keep learning them on a weekly basis,
and the first one - the "newborn" - you
should take particular attention to.
So Danish and Greek possibly in the
morning, what about Hungarian? Well, I've
tried to do Hungarian after doing Danish
and after learning Greek but I've just
realized that after that, I'm not I'm not
able to work because it's a lot of
intense work on languages first thing in
the morning and, you know, life gets in
the way, I also have to work, give lessons
teach, coaching, writing articles so I
told myself okay so two languages in the
morning when I'm fresh, and possibly one
language in the evening. I take language
courses language lessons with two
Hungarian teachers and I try to talk to
them around 1:00 PM and I rehearse and I
listen to these lessons after after
taking these lessons maybe 48 hours
later, possibly at night. So I just
distinguished the Danish & Greek routine
in the morning and then Hungarian in the
evening. On top of that, I'm also using a
magazine which is called MAGYARUL TANULOK and the reason why my routine
with Hungarian is even more relaxed is
because again I have I think I have an
upper intermediate level so I can be
even more relaxed and it's what I
normally do to keep my Hungarian going
and motivate myself is to you know get
get to go to Hungary on and off I'm
going to Hungary in a little bit so
that's more or less how I organize every
single day.
One thing that I've been doing for years
and it really works wonders
is to keep a logbook. I open the Google
Doc and at the end of each learning
session, I make sure that I go to the log
book and I write exactly the date what I
did and how long it took me.
Now for this specific project I have
created a logbook which includes all
three languages so every single day, at
the end of the day, I just copy each
entry and I transfer them into the
general logbook so that I can get a
clear picture of what I'm doing every
single day for these three languages.
So the trick here is that if every day, at
the end of a learning session, you put
your entry, and then you transfer all
these entries into the big logbook, you
will see the progress that you're making
not in one, not in two, but in THREE
languages, and that's an amazing feeling,
just as the feeling that a climber has
when you know halfway he looks back and
sees the path that he's covered that's
amazing that's amazing for your
motivation because you always have to
remember - and I can't stress this enough -
that language learning is a marathon and
learning three languages at the same
time it's like you know running three
marathons at the same time. You better
keep track of where are you going and
how much track you've covered. So to wrap
up: 1. First, it is really important to
establish priorities I don't recommend
normally to learn three languages at the
same time but if these three languages
two or three languages are at different
levels, that's fine. 2. Point number two is
that it's really important not only to
organize your time but to organize your
energy and your concentration. 3 And third
make sure that you keep accurate track
of your progress, do keep one single logbook
for each language but also make sure
that you have a bigger logbook where you
can see the entire framework and the
entire picture that you are drawing for
your future. So, if you've enjoyed the
video, please share it around if you
haven't subscribed, please subscribe and
click on the link below because there's
an amazing article waiting for you with
a big surprise: for the first time I've
decided to publish my Google Doc where
I'm writing each and every single day
what I do with these three languages so
you can see every single day you have
free access to what I do with comments
and tips, and considerations and
observations that are right there every
single day. Enjoy!
you